In the economy that we live in with AI,
client work, acquisition, things like
that, it is so much better to focus on
creator work in 2026 because it takes
the same amount of skill, energy, and
effort to build your own audience online
and sell your own stuff as it does to
cold DM a whole bunch of people who are
already outsourcing their crap to AI.
Not only that, but your creator business
compounds over year where you can get
clients, lose clients, and all that work
is theirs and gone, and you don't have
the assets anymore. You just built a
bunch of stuff for other people. You
stop trading time for money, i.e. they
stop paying you if you stop working for
them. But your creator brand continues
to grow and grow and grow because the
assets you built online. You don't have
to wait for somebody to tell you that
you could start working. I.e. you're
going to take a 100 hours chasing
clients before you even get to write a
single thing where in the creator
economy you can start writing today. You
can open a Substack today, start sending
emails today. The profit margins are
higher. It takes less work to make the
same amount of money. There's so many
variables to where it just doesn't make
sense to be doing client work in 2026.